hello everyone Happy Holidays Happy
Holidays to you and yours you and yours
I always wanted to say that um so we
have a dilemma here on film courage and
that dilemma is we have a show coming up
sunday december 26 it's the day after
Christmas I think they know that okay
sorry I had to jump in there was
something I had to jump in there with
something thank you and and so we're in
a bit of a quandary and that is that
we're not sure who oh is it who that's a
discussion for a whole other day okay
we're not sure who to ask um so we're
looking to you to help us either what do
you want you want to know do you want to
be on film courage do you want to be on
FL courage we want to know what we were
going to keep this lot available it's
our sort of holiday gift yeah so those
that we care about in love and yours
yeah or we alternate we like to give
alternatives here do you know someone
that you could recommend now that's kind
of a trick you sure because you know it
would be great if you could recommend
Tom Cruise yeah I doubt he's available
although we would love to have them on
so someone who is able to be on the show
on the 2016 yeah because what we're
going to do is we're in a compiled list
of those that are available and
interested in coming on film courage and
then here's our little twists here's our
haters are gifts to you we're going to
have you decide who you want to come on
film courage so first we need to know
who is available and who wants to come
on and then we can give our our holiday
gets everyone have you decide that's
exciting I'm excited about this yeah I'm
excited too and there are four ways to
contact us to nominate either yourself
or someone else and those ways are you
can contact us at film courage at gmail
or at film courage on Twitter or the
good old facebook or WWF encourage calm
and there's only says w WR sorry i'm
revealing my ignorance so with that we
wish you a wonderful holiday season and
we hope to hear
no we do we wish you a happy holiday
season and then thank you thank you yeah
for everything for everything yeah yeah
all right eggnog time